[Music]
honestly I've seen a bunch of the movies
that are on there and I'm mostly really
excited about scratching off and seeing
what image is gonna be on the other side
I hope it looks cool
I think the movie bucket-list posters a
really good idea there's so much to
watch nowadays Netflix doesn't really
help give you any good suggestions so it
would be really nice to have something
to tell you what good movie you should
watch I'm very indecisive I don't like
having to be the person to pick the
movie or the restaurant I hate stuff
like that so I really like the idea of
having this cool list where I can just
scratch off a movie and go through every
single one of them
I also like that there's a lot of
comedies on here like office space and
ghostbusters and Monty Python I think
that a lot of times people talk about
the best movies of all time comedies get
left off or get looked down upon
I see Scarface on here that is a movie I
think is really overrated there's a
million better gangster who's you to
watch oh my god they'd have been girls
on here weird
I would love this as a gift I honestly
would I think it would help me expand my
horizons when it comes to movies and
it's also kind of interactive which i
think is cool at the end you get this
nice little poster that you can just
hang up on your wall and see all the
movies that you just went through
there's a hundred movies on this list
like I can't even name a hundred movies
right now